BRAD ABRAMS: Good afternoon.
Thank you for coming.
In this talk, we're going
to show you how to build
backends, cloud-based backends
in for your amazing Android
applications.
I'm Brad Abrams.
I'm a product manager
on the cloud team.
DAVID CHANDLER: And I'm
David Chandler, an
Android developer advocate.
BRAD ABRAMS: So David, I haven't
seen you in a while.
How are you enjoying IO?
DAVID CHANDLER: It's great.
It's great.
Love to be here and meet
up with geeks from
all around the world.
You know, the only thing that I
think we need for IO is, we
need a way to find geeks.
Because there's lots of them
around, but I don't know what
everybody's interest is, and
when people scatter out at the
city at night.
BRAD ABRAMS: You know, I think
there's an app for that.
We've got a couple of hours.
We've got-- not a couple--
we've got 39 minutes.
We could probably build a
cloud-connected Android app to
solve just that problem.
DAVID CHANDLER: I think
you're right.
BRAD ABRAMS: What would
be on your wish list?
DAVID CHANDLER: I'd probably
want a map display.
And it would show me where
other geeks are.
They'd have a way to register
what they're interested in--
Android, Chrome, cloud,
et cetera.
And then maybe color code the
markers by their interests and
show them on the map.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yes.
So David, you really, they
shortened the session length
this year, so there's only
like 40 minutes.
I don't know if we're going to
have time to build all that.
But luckily, we launched a new
member of the Cloud Platform
family, the Mobile
Backend Starter.
And what this does is, it's a
no code server solution to
build a highly scalable,
cloud-based backend in for
your mobile applications.
It's built on App Engine,
so it was born to scale.
We've got built-in Google
Authentication, built-in
Google Cloud Messaging, and a
very cool Continuous Query
feature that we'll
show you about.
The Mobile Backend Starter
has two parts to it.
The first part is on the server
side with App Engine.
We define a few Cloud Endpoints
exposed over Rest
APIs to do generic data storage
and access from there.
And then it integrates with
Google Cloud Messaging to send
tickles down to the device.
And then on the device side,
we have a Client Library
that's tailored to that backend,
and then a place to
put your own application.
So with this David, how do
you think that would
look for your app?
DAVID CHANDLER: Well, we need to
come up with a map display,
so we could use the new
Android Maps V2 API.
And then use the Mobile Backend
Starter to make our
queries to the cloud, and get
the locations of geeks, and
report our own location
up as well.
BRAD ABRAMS: Sounds good.
So should we get started?
DAVID CHANDLER: Absolutely.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK.
Let's go.
So our story begins here at
the new Cloud Console.
This is the new integrated
experience for
all the cloud features.
So if you might have been used
to using API console in the
past, and eventually this will
also replace the App Engine
admin console.
But for now, both exist in
parallel until we get this one
all the way there.
So on this site, and I invite
you if you're watching this
online, to play along
with us here.
If you want to follow the
steps that I'm saying.
The Eng team would love it if
you just really slammed our
servers right now.
So you just go to
cloud.google.com/console and
create an app.
And then click on this
Get Started button.
There's a few samples
here to choose from.
One of them is this new
Mobile Backend.
Now for the sake of appeasing
the demo gods, I have already
deployed this a little
earlier this morning.
But the way this works is, you
just click on Deploy here.
And notice I can download--
all the backend source code
for this is available.
I can download that and do
whatever I want to with it.
Or I can just deploy that.
And this, without having to
install any App Engine SDK,
any tools on the client.
It deploys a fully-functional
App Engine app.
Everything we're going to
show you in this demo is
already in that app.
And that's deployed for you.
Once that deployment finishes,
you can click on the Settings
link there.
And that will open up the Admin
Experience for this
mobile backend.
In it's actually part of
the App Engine app
that we've just deployed.
And you can see here, we
start locked down.
It is locked down by default.
and the messaging is disabled
by default.
So it's locked down so no one
can access your server.
So what we want to do for
development mode is flip this
to Open Access.
And that means everybody can
access your endpoint.
The next step we need to do,
we come back over here.
We did step one, step two.
Step three is to download
an Android client.
So we have all of the source
code available
for an Android client.
That works super well in the
Android IDE or in Eclipse.
So we're going to use Eclipse
with ADT, the latest Android
Development Tools installed.
And I've actually already
downloaded that and have the
project here in Eclipse,
so you can
see what you're getting.
There's the base files that
handle accessing the server.
And then there's a sample that
comes with it with this Guest
Book example, which we'll
take a look at.
And then the main configuration
place to look at
is this cons.java file.
And we'll look at this
a little bit over the
course of the talk.
But there is a few constants
here that you fill in to be
able to wire these
things together.
So what we need to do is wire
up our client to our server,
just so they can talk.
If you're familiar with App
Engine, it has a URL format
that matches the project
ID that we gave it.
And then we just give
the project ID in
the cons file here.
I've actually already got
that up and running.
I've already deployed that.
So if we just switch over to
the camera, which is here.
So here we have, this is
the Guest Book app.
This is what comes by default
with the project.
And we can just send
a message here, "Hi
IO." And I click Send.
When I click Send, what it's
going to do is send a REST
request up to the server.
The server will store that data
in App Engine's noSQL
data store.
And then we'll get a Ack back
on the client here.
And just to show that,
let me switch back.
I am--
DAVID CHANDLER: Four.
BRAD ABRAMS: I'm four.
Sorry about that.
OK.
We'll just switch back here.
And let me show you in the
new Cloud Console.
So if we switch up here, you
can see our beautiful new
Cloud Data Store Explorer.
And we click on Queries.
And we can see that entity
that we [INAUDIBLE].
Notice there's that
Guest Book entity.
You can create your
own entities.
And they can have any fields
that you want them to have.
And you can see, here's our
Guest Book Entity and there's
the "Hi IO." So in about five
minutes, we've already built a
cloud-connected Android app.
But I think there's
more we can do.
I think for the Geek Serendipity
app David's going
to build, he's going to want
more than just storing the
state in the cloud.
He's going to want to be sitting
at a coffee shop and
just see geeks pop in on his
mobile device, without having
to refresh the application.
DAVID CHANDLER: In case I can't
recognize them when they
walk with their Google apps.
BRAD ABRAMS: Right.
Exactly.
So there's a couple of
approaches to this.
This is not the right slide.
There's a couple of approaches
to this.
And we don't have our--
anyway, yes.
There's a couple of approaches
to this.
One would be polling.
We could, from the client of
the app, we could every few
minutes, we could go up
to the server and
say, is anybody new?
Is anything new?
And get the results
back there.
But that would be bad.
That would be expensive in
battery life, expensive in
network resources, and would use
a lot of server resources.
So rather than that,
we're going to use
Google Cloud Messaging.
It's the same technology that
Google uses to power Gmail on
Android or Google Chat.
There's a persisted connection
that's maintained between
Google's data centers and all
the phones that have those
Google Experience
apps on them.
And your code, your applications
can use that same
channel to be able to
send notifications.
So we're going to use that.
So there's really two
steps to doing that.
The, first step is we need to
know who is sending the
notifications.
And in our case, it's going to
be the Mobile Backend Starter
that we just deployed is going
to send those notifications.
So the way we do that is, let's
come back to our app
here and click on APIs.
And you can see, I've already
ahead of time turned on the
Google Cloud Messaging
for Android.
So you have to enable
this API.
And then, we go into the Mobile
Backend Starter, and we
need to give it the API key.
This is where we're going to use
that to pass along to say,
here's who's sending the
Push notification.
So in order to do that, in order
to get that key, we'll
go into the New Cloud Console
and we'll register a new
application.
And we'll just call this
our Mobile Backend.
And it's just a generic
web app.
And we'll register it.
And we'll actually use this a
couple of times when we do
Auth as well.
But for this time, all it asks
for is that server key.
So we just grab that server
key and put it in here.
And we've done everything we
need to enable our server side
for Push notification.
The last bit is just to
put the project ID
that cons.jafa file.
Once we've done that and deploy,
then we get the same
Guest Book application.
But now if David were to send us
some messages, David's got
that same app running
over there.
Oh, and we need to switch to
it, so you can see it.
So what David's going to do is
he's going to find the app.
And then he's going to start
sending us messages.
When he sends a message from his
phone, that's going to do
a REST request up to the server,
going to store that
data in data store.
And then there's a technology
called Perspective Search that
is looking at changes
in the data store.
And when it sees a change,
it's going to send a
notification over to Google
Cloud Messaging.
Google Cloud Messaging will then
find the subscribers and
send a message down
to my phone.
And you can see, David's using
all his creativity at this
point to come up with very
creative things.
And you can see sort of hands
free, we're getting
notifications.
So just a few minutes in, and
we've already got a pretty
functional application
with just setting a
few variables there.
So at this point, David, I think
we're probably ready for
you to start putting some
map goodness on here.
DAVID CHANDLER: OK.
Excellent.
So I have started project based
on the cloud backend
that Brad has on his machine.
And I've put on a Map activity
in it using the
new Maps API V2.
So there's just a map fragment
and a very simple activity,
which I'll show you here.
And you have to paste your
API key into your
Android manifest as well.
Don't forget that if you're
setting up maps.
Let me zoom in on this code a
little bit so you can see a
little bit about it.
We just have a Setup method
where we obtain the reference
to the map.
And then we enable our location,
which makes the
Location Services work.
So that gives you the Locator
button in the upper
right in the app.
And that's really about all
there is to it for getting the
basic map up.
So what we want to do is, as
soon as we launch the app with
the map, we want to
find our location.
And we're going to use the
integrated Google Location
Services that work
with the Maps V2.
And then we want to do something
whenever it comes
back and notifies us it has
a good location for us.
So there is a listener called On
My Location Change listener
that we can set.
And that will allow us act
on that information.
So what we'll set that--
set On My Location
Change listener.
And I'm going to just let
this class implement it.
Let me blow this up again
a little bit.
So we're getting an error there
because we need to let
this class implement
that method.
So we'll go ahead
and add that.
And then, oops--
scroll back.
We need to add the
actual method.
So I've got a little code here
I'm going to paste in from the
snippet on my Location Change
handler and we'll fixed
imports here.
Zoom back in on it.
And you can see, it's doing
Send My Location.
And then we've got a little code
further down to do that.
And it's not implemented yet,
so let's go ahead and
implement this method as well.
So to send our location to the
server, we're going to use the
cloud's backend sample
code that's here.
And it's really pretty
straightforward.
We just create a generic entity,
that's the way the
cloud, the Mobile Backend
Starter works, is it gives you
generic cloud services that you
can send and receive these
generic cloud entities.
We're just creating a
new cloud entity.
And we're making of
kind of Geek.
This works really well with
the App Engine Data Store
because it is schemaless.
So you can create any
number of kinds and
properties on the fly.
That makes it actually it very
easy for us write this kind of
application right now.
So we'll put in a few things.
Our interest is cloud.
Our location is what we
just got from the
Location Change Handler.
And then we call
getcloudBackend.update, and
this is one of the built-in
methods that's available to us
as part of the Mobile
Backend Starter.
And because in Android
everything should be
asynchronous, we pass it a
Callback handler that will get
called when the request
completes.
And when the request completes,
then we draw a
marker on the map.
The reason getCloudBackend is
in red is because I need to
let this activity extend Cloud
Backend activity now, instead
of Fragment activity.
So there we go.
Now all those features
are available to me.
You can look here and see that
method should be OK.
So let's take this and
run it on the phone.
It'll take just a second here.
Let me get the phone
plugged in.
OK.
And a little trick I learned
just this morning actually, is
that if you want to install an
app on your phone but not run
it yet-- which I'm going to
do because of the ethernet
situation here--
you can just change your run
configuration and tell it to
do nothing on launch.
And that will build and install
the app on the phone,
but it won't actually launch
the activity yet.
So we're going to go ahead
and do that now.
Run as Android application.
See it's building.
We'll wait for it to
come over here.
And then we'll go plug the phone
into the ethernet and
show the map on the camera.
OK.
It looks like it's
already there.
I'll grab this.
BRAD ABRAMS: Not that we're
paranoid about the network.
DAVID CHANDLER: Yeah.
These Galaxy Nexus phones have
the capability to do USB to
ethernet, which works very
well for us here.
So here is our app--
comes up with our basic
map display.
We have Location Services
available.
And then when we touch that,
we should see that
it will locate us.
BRAD ABRAMS: You should see.
DAVID CHANDLER: Very
interesting.
It doesn't seem to be able to
find a location for us.
Let's see if we scroll the map
over and zoom in a little bit.
Well, something new
every demo.
BRAD ABRAMS: Awesome.
DAVID CHANDLER: OK.
BRAD ABRAMS: So David's
going to debug that.
DAVID CHANDLER: Yeah.
I think, I think maybe not.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK.
DAVID CHANDLER: I think we'll
go to the next stage.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK.
Great.
Yeah.
Yeah, so David's going to
debug that while I go--
so David is now theoretically
sending our
location up to the server.
DAVID CHANDLER: Yes.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah.
David is now sending our
location up to the server.
And I have the digerati
following me all the time.
And I think with our server
being open and my location
being sent up there, that's
sort of a bad combination.
So what we want to do is
lock down our server.
We're going to lock it down so
only our Android client can
call our server.
Just because there's REST
endpoints out there, doesn't
mean we want everybody
else to call them.
We only want our client app
to call those endpoints.
Now there's a number of options
for how to go do this.
Some people have been put
secrets in their Android app--
some token that they generate
that's in their app.
And they send that up
on each request.
But that has a obvious problem,
because how many of
you have ever unzipped
an APK before?
Right.
And so if you can do
it, a lot of people
could probably do that.
And so those secrets
are discoverable.
So rather than using some secret
that we put into the
APK, we're going to use a
mechanism that's built right
into the Android OS.
And that's, all Android
apps are signed.
There's a digital
signature that's
cryptographically strong.
And we're going to use
that signature.
That signature is actually what
the Google Play Store
uses when it is updating apps.
When it's finding which app to
update, it uses that signature
to ensure that you're
the same publisher.
So what we're going
to do is use that
signature on the client.
And we're going to give that
a token generated from that
signature up to the server.
And that'll be sure
the requests only
come from our app.
So to do that, what we'll do
is come back over to the
Mobile Backend Settings page.
And then, it's asking for an
Android client ID that I've
already filled in.
So the way you get that Android
client ID is back in
the cloud console, you
register a new app.
So click on Register App.
I've called it Android
client--
client.
And then you just give it the
package name and the SHA1
fingerprint.
The SHA1 fingerprint is the
interesting one to get.
That you run the Keytool
command over your
debug.keystore file if
you're in Debug mode.
And that keystore file
is generated for you
automatically by the
Android ADT.
And it's in the--
it's usually in your root
directory in dot Android.
So anyway, we generate that.
And then once we have that,
we have a client ID
that's all wired up.
So we just take that client
ID and hand it
to the mobile backend.
So that handles the
first step.
The second step of this is, if
you noticed, we're actually
using OAuth to do
this security.
And OAuth is tried and true
technology, but somebody may
associate OAuth with the OAuth
Consent Dialogue that you may
have seen before, like when
you're trying to access say
Google Plus data or Google Docs
on behalf of somebody.
They'll get a prompt that says,
do you want to allow
this app to access your
Google Docs data?
That's a OAuth Consent screen.
And that makes sense
in that scenario.
But in our scenario, we have
the Geek Serendipity app on
the client accessing the Geek
Serendipity Backend.
That's not one where--
the OAuth Consent screen
would be sort of silly.
Do you want the frontend of this
app to be able to talk to
its own backend?
And that's not a choice
that we think is
meaningful to users.
And so what we do is, we can
suppress that screen so it
doesn't get seen, if we know the
publisher is the same on
the client and server
side of the app.
If we know it's your backend and
your frontend, you don't
need to see that screen.
So the way we prove that it's
your backend and your frontend
is we use a web client ID.
And so you get the
web client ID--
this is that--
yeah, this is the Mobile
Backend that we created
earlier for getting the Google
Cloud Messaging to work.
And before we used
the server key.
And now, we're going to use
the OAuth client ID.
So we just grab this
OAuth client ID.
And you put it in the second
field here for
a Web Client ID.
And then you also put it
in your Android app.
So it needs to be in both.
Now this is not a secret.
Somebody could unpack your APK
and get that, and they still
couldn't access your backend.
It just proves that you're the
same user on the frontend and
the backend.
OK
And then there's
one more step.
So the last thing is very easy
and that is that because we're
using Google authentication in
here, we have the same notion
of who a user is on the
client and the server.
That's built into the App Engine
framework and it's
built in to Android.
So it's a very seamless
experience.
So I've have already loaded
that up on this phone, and
let's switch over.
So I loaded this app just a
minute ago onto this phone.
And you can see now, when I run
the app, it's giving me a
chance to login.
And all of the--
most Android phones
have [INAUDIBLE]
IDs, Google IDs, associated
with them.
So I'll just log in
with this one.
And now what's happened
is, it's gone out and
validated who I am.
What's the secret?
DAVID CHANDLER: The secret is in
order to know your location
it needs one of two pieces
of information--
either GPS--
BRAD ABRAMS: Awesome.
DAVID CHANDLER: --or Wi-Fi.
We have Wi-Fi off, because
we had it hard wired.
BRAD ABRAMS: Awesome
DAVID CHANDLER: And now
we have Wi-Fi on.
BRAD ABRAMS: Give it a whirl.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
BRAD ABRAMS: Fantastic.
So now it knows who I am and
where I am, and we're looking
for an acknowledgement that
it knows who I am.
And we can switch over and
see the data store.
Is it going to work?
OK.
DAVID CHANDLER: I think so.
BRAD ABRAMS: Give it
one more second.
Let's switch over and see.
I'll just run this.
It's not there.
DAVID CHANDLER: Let's
try closing the app.
BRAD ABRAMS: So now
turn off Wi-Fi.
We're done with-- we
know where we are.
Now we can use the internet--
that we can use the hardwire.
DAVID CHANDLER: No,
I don't think so.
I think we want to close the
app and then come back in.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK.
DAVID CHANDLER: Sorry.
BRAD ABRAMS: Just
one demo glitch.
DAVID CHANDLER: Yeah.
BRAD ABRAMS: We really need
the ethernet to be able to
tell us where we are.
So what we've done so far,
is we've built a
backend on App Engine.
Just click once to deploy
that backend.
And we've stored our
state there.
We've shown Push notification,
the easiest GCM wire-up I
think you've ever seen.
And we've showed using
a map and logging in.
DAVID CHANDLER: Sorry.
I did something wrong.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK.
All right.
DAVID CHANDLER: We'll move
on to the next thing.
BRAD ABRAMS: And so that
will now store your
data up on the server.
So you want to switch
the next one?
DAVID CHANDLER: Yes.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK.
DAVID CHANDLER: OK.
So now that we are sending our
location to the server.
BRAD ABRAMS: Sorry.
OK.
DAVID CHANDLER: We'll go ahead
and proceed with the next
stage, which is we want
to find out where all
the other geeks are.
So we want to query
the server.
And if you could put
up the slide.
BRAD ABRAMS: Oh,
I forgot that.
DAVID CHANDLER: --the
Keynode slide.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK.
DAVID CHANDLER: I'll tell you
about the Continuous Query
Capability that we're going
to use to do that.
So this is a feature of the
Mobile Backend Starter project
that uses several App Engine
features as well.
There's a API [INAUDIBLE]
preview
called Prospective Search.
And what that does is, anytime
data comes in that matches the
parameters of your query, then
App Engine will notify your
app on the server side
that some matching
data has been found.
So we're going to use that
to our advantage here.
Any time a new location update
gets posted, then our Apple
get notified on the
server side.
And the Mobile Backend Starter
project takes that further,
and will send a GCM message
to our app running on
the phone, as well.
So the flow looks like this.
In step one, a new location
update comes from the phone.
It gets put in the server.
In step two, the App Engine
Perspective Search API
notifies the server side
part of our Mobile
Backend Starter app.
That sends a GCM message--
Google Cloud Messaging-- to
the client in step three.
Then in step four, we re-query
to get the latest data from
the server.
And then finally, step five, we
draw the markers on the map
with that most recent data.
So I'm going to go now write
the code that actually does
this in our app.
So we'll again take a look
into our Map activity.
And the first thing we want
to do is write a query.
I'm just going to stroll
down a little bit here.
That will go out and get
the geek locations.
So let me paste in
some code here--
query geeks.
And show you what
that looks like.
All the capability that I just
described on that slide is
called Continuous Queries, is
what we're calling it right
now on this project.
And so the first part of our
query is to write a handler
that will receive the results.
So we have a On Complete handler
and we're just going
to draw markers.
Simple enough.
Then to actually register the
query, we call Get Cloud
Backend, dot Clear
All Subscription.
Now, the notion of a Continuous
Query, you can
subscribe to queries
on the server.
So we want to clear any existing
subscriptions, and
then set up a new one.
So we say New Cloud Query
for kind Geek.
We're just going to get the top
50 geeks sorted in order
of the most recent
location updates.
And we're going to make the
scope future and past.
So again, this is a feature of
the Mobile Backend Starter
that lets you say, I want to be
notified of future matches
to this query, as
well as present.
And if you think about the
amount of code that you have
to write to do that all
manually, setting up GCM,
keeping track of this data,
it is actually a very nice
convenience.
And then we actually register
this query by calling
getCloudBackend.list.
And we pass it our query
and our handler.
So the code that runs up here
in lines 72 and 73, the On
Complete handler will get
invoked any time there's a new
location update that gets
sent to the server.
Then all the clients who are
subscribed to that query will
get notified so they
can update their
map displays as well.
So we've made a query method.
Now we actually need
to call this.
And we only want to
call this query.
Now we have authentication
turned on, it's going to
enforce that at the
server side.
So we only want to call it if
we're already authenticated.
There's another method that's
useful to do that in our
project called On Post Create.
We can inherit this from the
Cloud Backend activity.
And here's where we're going to
call our Query Geeks method
to register our query--
so only gets called after
we're authenticated.
And then lastly, I just want
to remove my Draw Marker
method, because now in our On
Complete handler, we're
drawing all the markers.
So that's the final
code for that.
Let me go ahead and put
it on the phone.
BRAD ABRAMS: You have
a suggestion?
DAVID CHANDLER: Right.
We'll do run as Android app
again to get it here.
And once it appears, I will
cross my fingers, walk over
there, stick it under
the camera.
Wi-Fi's still on on this one.
You'll need Wi-Fi on
for the second part
of the demo as well.
OK.
So here we go.
Going to give it a whirl here.
I'll switch back to
the camera view.
And we'll try the app.
Authentication is enabled now,
so I have to log in.
The map should be coming up.
You know what I didn't do.
I didn't plug in the
ethernet, but Wi-Fi
appears to be working.
Yay.
BRAD ABRAMS: Shoot.
DAVID CHANDLER: And
we'll locate.
OK.
And there is a marker--
actually two markers,
which is exciting.
Have you already launched
the app?
BRAD ABRAMS: No.
DAVID CHANDLER: OK.
Well.
BRAD ABRAMS: You may
see one more.
Let's see.
DAVID CHANDLER: In the advanced
section of this
presentation, we will discuss
how the clone ourselves--
or at least, our Android
devices.
Yep, I saw it appear.
BRAD ABRAMS: Did you
see a third one?
DAVID CHANDLER: Yes, I saw
the third one appear as
Brad did the demo.
You remember, there
were two, right.
Nothing up my sleeve.
A third marker appeared.
That is the Continuous Query in
action when he ran the app.
Thank you very much.
BRAD ABRAMS: So, did you
want to do that slide?
DAVID CHANDLER: Yes, let
me get that up here.
I'll switch back to mine.
I wanted to say a little bit
more about a couple of things.
First, the Mobile Backend
Starter project is brought to
you by a team at Google called
the Cloud Solutions Team.
And I wanted to acknowledge
the engineers there--
I'll be calling Greg, because no
one can pronounce his name
properly, Kaz Sato,
and Jenny Lo.
The Cloud Solutions Team is
involved with helping App
Engine customers figure out
the optimum technical
solutions to run--
cloud customers,
more generally.
And they also publish best
practices white papers you can
find them at cloud.google.com
under the Solutions Section.
I wanted to mention a little bit
more async tasks, as well
because part of the magic that
the Mobile Backend Starter is
doing for you is to run
off the UI thread.
And Android is behind
the scenes.
That Cloud Backend activity is
actually creating a new thread
for the network request.
But that's all.
You're insulated from that.
You don't have to
worry about it.
Even better would be to use
services on the Android
platform, and that's something
that we're looking at
extending that project to do.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK.
Thank you.
So I think now we have a very
full-featured app, and its
cloud connected.
I think the Mobile Backend
Starter has
served us really well.
We haven't had to do any
server code yet.
But I'm a server guy.
And I was talking earlier,
I think there's a few App
Engine-- who's sort of an
App Engine guy here?
Are you guys missing writing
code on the server?
I know I am.
So I constructed a reason
to have to write
some code on the server.
So both David and I are
little bit data geeks.
Being at Google, we love
processing lots of data.
And so we want to log everything
about the user
experience on this app-- how do
people use, how they pan,
what do they do on the app--
so that we can do data
processing on it, and learn how
to make the app better.
But the Mobile Backend doesn't
have a logging mechanism--
doesn't have any way to store
stuff in logs yet, although
they will probably add it
right after this talk.
But for now anyway,
it's an excuse to
write some server code.
So we're going to write our own
custom cloud endpoint that
is part of this Backend
Starter.
And then we're going to call
that endpoint from a Client
Library in the client.
So let me show you
how this goes.
So what I've done is I've gone
out to GitHub and I've
downloaded the source code for
the Mobile Backend Starter.
As we've said, everything
in this thing, the
source code's available.
So if you don't like something
Greg, did you can go and
change that.
And so what I'm going to
do, I've got that.
And I'm just going to drag in an
end point I wrote earlier.
And this is the world's simplest
cloud endpoint.
So it's got that @API attribute
that indicates to
App Engine at that we're going
to expose this is a REST API.
And then right here, we're
seeing where we are defining
what its name will be in the
Client Library and what the
REST interface should be.
And then, it's very simple.
We just call log.info and put
that in the App Engine logs.
So I've already deployed this a
little earlier this morning.
And what's very cool about
Cloud Endpoints is that
there's this neat URL.
If you go to _ah/api/explorer,
then you can actually view the
API Explorer for
your interface.
So what we saw earlier was
the Mobile Backend.
And now I've just added a new
one called Cloud Login API.
And that's got the same name I
gave it in the source code.
And now if I "hi from the web
app," then this goes out and
it calls my interface.
And if I look at the App Engine
logs for this, you can
see there is that log, "hi from
the web." So, very nice
experience there.
Now what we want to
do is called this
from our client app.
So in order to do that, what
I need to do is generate a
Client Library.
So I'm just going to right click
on this and find the
Generate Cloud Endpoints
Client Library feature.
And this is going to go out.
It's, going to take the
discovery document, the
description of that interface,
go out to the web to a service
we provide that will generate
a strongly-typed
Android-optimized Client Library
for our service, and
then download it, and put it
right here in this project.
There it is--
Client Logging.
DAVID CHANDLER: That
functionality, by the way, is
provided by the Google
plug-in for Eclipse.
BRAD ABRAMS: That's right.
And then, we just need to copy
it over, very simple.
I'm just going to
drag this over.
And now we need to add it to our
Build Path, so we're going
to right click on this and
use a source folder.
So now this to be part
of the build.
And then, I just have a very
simple bit of source code to
add to the client to actually
do the calls.
And let me show you what
this looks like.
So this is my Cloud
Log function.
It's very simple.
In the constructor, we take the
unique ID of the Android
app that we're using.
So we can tell in the logs
what's happening where.
And then in a thread, I
am going and doing the
asynchronous call up
to the server.
And that's right here--
service.logs.log, passing that
message, and doing execute.
In just a couple more-- if we
had a couple of minutes--
I would wire this up into the
UI, but it's very simple.
You just call this Log method
and we do that request each
time up to the server.
You might want to do batching,
but for the demo to be snappy,
I decided not to.
There's nothing really to see
on here, but I have this on
the phone and I'm just going
to pan around a little bit,
generate some log data
hopefully, if
the connections working.
Then if I come back to my logs,
I should see new logs.
And we do in fact, see logs
from client, right,
with a unique ID.
And this is for example,
on my location changed.
So we've shown you how to add
custom logging to the custom
endpoints to your Mobile
Backend Starter.
So with, that I think we're
pretty much done.
Let's--
DAVID CHANDLER: OK.
BRAD ABRAMS: --wrap up.
DAVID CHANDLER: All right.
Everything that we've done
today is available.
The Mobile Backend Starter, of
course, you can get to off
cloud.google.com in
the Cloud Console,
as Brad showed earlier.
The demo code is going to
be posted soon, as well.
And we also created a little
more refined version of the
app called Geek Serendipity,
which you can download in the
Play Store.
I may drop that on the camera
real quick here, just so you
can see it in operation.
We sent it out the other
day and allowed a few
people get in on it.
So you can see, it'll just put
markers on the map for you,
showing different types
of geeks in the area.
So we hope you enjoy using the
Mobile Backend Starter.
And we have one minute
and a half left.
If there's a quick question,
we could take that.
Yes, right here.
AUDIENCE: Do you need
to inherit from the
Cloud Backend activity?
DAVID CHANDLER: Do You need
to inherit from the
Cloud Backend activity?
Currently, yes.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DAVID CHANDLER: Yes, we are
looking at moving it into a
fragment or otherwise
abstracting that capability,
so that you don't
have to extend.
Yes, behind you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: There's
a microphone right
in the center aisle.
DAVID CHANDLER: OK.
Yeah, please step to
the microphone.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So What would be the difference
between using that
Cloud Messaging and web sockets
or Channel APIs?
DAVID CHANDLER: What would be
the difference between using
Google Cloud Messaging, web
sockets, or other APIs?
AUDIENCE: Channel APIs.
DAVID CHANDLER: Or
a Channel API?
OK.
Google Cloud Messaging is really
optimized for phone use
because it'll send the
updates over the air.
It's written in such a way
to be battery efficient.
And it is a true
Push mechanism.
Some of those others maintain
long-running connections.
I'm not sure they're designed
as much for Android,
specifically.
So I think Google Cloud
Messaging would be the most
battery efficient.
BRAD ABRAMS: I think
we're out of time.
So thank you very much.
Appreciate it.
DAVID CHANDLER: Thank you.